Disney's Encanto is full of hilarious, magical
moments, from Luisa and Isabela's amazing
songs to over-caffeinated kids and a sneaky
shapeshifting cousin.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm counting down the top 11 funniest
and most entertaining scenes in Encanto.
Spoilers ahead, so take care.
Of the three main village kids who pop up
in the movie, caffeinated kid has the funniest
moments.
There's his feverish demand to know all the
family's powers during the opening song...
Just tell us what everyone can do!
And that's why coffee's for grown-ups!
And what about the way he still hangs on to
his coffee cup even when he's kicking a football?
And how he revs himself up with caffeine to
help rebuild the Casita.
Encanto co-director Jared Bush has revealed
his official name is "Pumped Juancho"
As well as being adorably amusing, the caffeinated
kid is also a nod to the Colombian custom
of children drinking coffee.
It's so comical during the first song how
Mirabel has to constantly dodge questions
from the kids about her own gift.
And when they eventually find out she doesn't
have one, she's humorously brought crashing
back down to reality by a little girl.
I am just as special as the rest of my family.
All right, guys, where do I drop the wagon?
Maybe your Gift is being in denial.
I made a rainbow!
Camilo's shape-shifting abilities provide
plenty of laughs...
Mirabel!
...including when he pretends to be his sister...
Camilo!
Stop pretending you're Dolores so you can
have seconds.
Worth a shot.
Ah!
...when he makes fun of Isabela by turning
into her suitor, and when he gets a shock
as Bruno and Mirabel race nosily through the
walls of the house.
And, amusingly, when his shape-shifting gets
out of control, his head turns into a very
young child who sprouts an enormous moustache.
Bruno, who's been living alone for years,
gets a heartbreakingly humorous moment with
his alter egos when Mirabel asks him if he's
been repairing the cracks in the house:
All the patching's done by Hernando.
Who is Hernando?
I'm Hernando and I'm scared of nothing!
I used to say my real Gift was "acting."
I'm Jorge.
I make the spackle.
By the way, "Jorge" pops up again briefly
during the finale as the Madrigals rebuild
their home.
And how absolutely adorable is the scene where
shy little Antonio gets his powers...
...and communicates with his new animal friends...
Uh-huh.
I understand you.
...rides through his rainforest room on the
back of a jaguar, bounces about on a hammock,
and swings by on a snake!
And, frankly, let's face it, more movies could
benefit from adding capybaras!
There's some wonderful little details in this
scene too:
if you look carefully, you can see Dolores
put her hands over her ears as the crowd's
cheers become too much for her super-hearing.
And what about the hilarious way that the
perfectly poised golden child Isabela swings
onto the scene as the family prepares for
Antonio's gift ceremony:
Did someone say flowers?
Isabela!
Our angel!
Please don't clap.
Thank you.
Oh, it's nothing.
I love everything about this moment from the
way the murky scene changes to golden light
as Isabela works her magic, to the priceless
look on Mirabel's face as she watches her
effortlessly graceful sister swing by adored
by everyone there, to the serious Rapunzel
vibes I get from Isabela's magical swinging
vines.
And to cap it all, Isabela literally throws
her gift in Mirabel's face!
The incredibly catchy Cha-cha style of "We
Don't Talk About Bruno" is an ingenious way
to show everything Mirabel's estranged uncle
is blamed for in the family.
I love Pepa and Félix's dance routine as
they explain how Bruno got inside her head
causing her to create a hurricane on their
wedding day.
And the way Bruno's painted as a villain,
with Camilo shape-shifting and singing about
"rats upon his back", is darkly humorous;
then there's the townsfolk blaming him for
their woes shows how everyone uses him as
a scapegoat for totally ordinary things that
can happen to anyone.
And if you watch carefully, there's a fantastic
detail in the background, which some of our
eagle-eyed viewers spotted, as a hooded Bruno
bops along to the music behind Dolores and
Mirabel.
As the song ends, Dolores reveals she overheard
Bruno's vision of the magic dying and the
house breaking apart, which leads into the
hilariously memorable dinner scene with Isabela's
suitor Mariano,
but just before we get to that, I want to
thank our video's sponsor HelloFresh who make
getting a tasty home-cooked meal on your table
a lot easier.
HelloFresh delivers a box full of exactly
the right ingredients and recipes you need
for a week's worth of delicious, healthy meals,
saving you a ton of time on grocery shopping
and prep, plus getting the precise amount
you need for each meal reduces food waste.
Every week there's a stack of options to choose
from including family-friendly, calorie smart,
pescatarian, and veggie, as well as quick-and-easy
recipes that take as little as 20 to 30 minutes
to make.
A couple of meals I've made so far from my
first box are this delicious Spicy Mushroom
Mapo Tofu with spinach and jasmine rice and
sea bass fish and chips with tasty lemon-zest
garlic mayo and mixed leaf salad.
And you can make eating healthy and fresh
an easy new goal for 2022 with our amazing
offer of up to 16 meals completely free, plus
3 special gifts when you sign up for a new
meal kit at HelloFresh.com and use the code
FLICKS16.
HelloFresh gets produce from farm to your
doorstep in under a week for peak freshness
and for my next meal I can't wait to try out
this Turmeric Roasted Cauliflower Lentil and
Coconut Dhal.
So, go to HelloFresh.com and use code FLICKS16
for up to 16 free meals AND 3 surprise gifts!
The proposal dinner with Mariano and Isabela
is an absolute comedic gem as every thread
in the story collides to spectacular effect.
Mirabel watches in agony as Dolores begins
to reveal the secret about Bruno's vision.
And the reactions of each family member as
the story passes along the line builds both
the laughs and the sense of impending doom.
And her antics as she attempts to cover up
the house literally splitting apart...
You're doing great.
...draw looks that could kill from Isabela.
As if that wasn't enough, one of Antonio's
coatis steals a piece of Bruno's vision and
Luisa breaks down as she struggles to move
the piano.
Chaos descends and Dolores blurts out:
Mirabel found Bruno's vision.
She's in it.
She's gonna destroy the magic and now, we're
all doomed!
The house cracks and one of Isabela's flowers
sprouts out of the floor and sucker-punches
Mariano in the face, foreshadowing her reveal
later that she doesn't really want to marry
him.
And to top it all off, the townspeople pop
up with their laughably well-timed congratulations.
¡Felicidades!
After Bruno's rat pack lead Mirabel to find
where her uncle's been hiding all these years,
we get some disgustingly funny moments thanks
to his little rodent friends,
who use his hairbrush and his toothbrushes
to clean themselves, run the old-fashioned
record player using it like an exercise wheel,
fight over food scraps in his trousers, and
provide free entertainment.
What do you like?
Sports?
This scene is a sneaky reference to Colombia's
historic match against West Germany in the
1990 World Cup and there's even a nod to "El
Cole", Colombia's most colourful best-known
football fan.
And the telenovela plot about a forbidden
love involving an aunt...
Their love could never be.
...is a shout-out to Gabriel García Márquez's
novel One Hundred Years of Solitude which
heavily influenced Encanto.
Hat-tip to everyone in my video comments who
spotted these!
The rats also reveal Bruno's whereabouts to
Dolores...
The rats talking in the walls.
...and to Antonio:
The rats told me everything.
Don't eat those.
(GROWLS)
And the little rodents put in another appearance
at the end of the movie as the family's photographers!
Mirabel's horrified reaction when she finds
out that to save the miracle she has to make
peace with Isabela is just perfect.
(GROWLS)
Look at how reluctant Mirabel is and how she
tries to get it over with as quickly as possible...
So, we should just hug.
Let's hug it out.
compared to her sister who drags it out, gloatingly
demanding an apology for the ruined dinner
with Mariano.
Go on.
Apologize.
Mirabel just can't go through with it though
and her accusations...
you selfish...
(GASPS)
...entitled princess!
...finally get Isabela to reveal her true
feelings.
I chuckled as she makes flowers sprout up
into Mirabel's face as her anger at having
to be constantly perfect erupts.
As for her song, there's definite shades of
Elsa's "Let It Go" song about it, which is
funny given the Elsa-like poses in these flower
statues, one of which Isabela goes on to decapitate.
The multi-coloured world Isabela creates for
herself, embracing vibrant and sharply-contrasting
colours, is just gorgeous and a world away
from her previous pastel colours.
There's even a nice edge to her song as she
grows some canivorous plants.
And it's impossible not to laugh when Isa
makes another flower pop up out of nowhere
to bop Mariano in the nose again!
Luisa's burn-out anthem, 'Surface Pressure',
is an insanely catchy, cleverly thought-out
piece of storytelling by Lin-Manuel Miranda
about the burden of impossible expectations.
And the whole sequence is beautifully animated,
with loads of entertaining moments and ingenious
hidden details,
from the Titanic-style ship with the Madrigal
name on the side heading for an iceberg, to
Luisa shooting into the sky in a superhero
pose, to Mirabel desperately holding on to
a seemingly storm-tossed ship, but when the
camera pulls back we see she's actually riding
the waves of Luisa's bulging bicep.
And then there's the donkeys!
Everywhere!
They're Luisa's backing dancers, and get some
fun Busby Berkeley-style shots during the
song;
they're the band playing on the Madrigal ship;
they're the audience in the battle with Cerberus;
they weigh down Luisa's scales;
and they're decked out like unicorns with
pink eye shadow to match the candy-coloured
clouds as Luisa rides them through the sky
in a rare moment of joy.
Then there's this moment where they slow-mo
fall through the air, which I just love.
And one's even there at the end of the movie
with a tray of drinks to help Luisa finally
relax!
And if you want to discover even more brilliant
details and Disney easter eggs hidden in Encanto,
tap here to watch my Things You Missed video.
There's also a link in the video description.
So what are your favourite moments in Encanto?
Let me know in the comments below and if you
enjoyed this, then do like and share this
video;
I really appreciate it.
You can also tap left to learn all about the
incredible deleted scenes and characters cut
from the final movie, such as Isabela's magical
potato people.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!